[Music]
back now at 7 30 on cbs mornings and we
have all of course seen the harrowing
images from the war in ukraine millions
of refugees struggling to flee the
fighting often in extreme peril as they
do so but we have to remember that many
have not made it out alive charlie
dagetta spoke to a man who told the
story of his own family's desperate bid
for survival charlie good morning
good morning tony since the invasion
began we've been reporting about the
horrific civilian death toll we have to
remember to put a human face on those
numbers each death tells a tragic story
of loss this is just one of them
the missile strike that tore through a
line of people even as they were trying
to flee
showed the savagery of this war and a
reckless disregard for human life
erpin had come under heavy bombardment
for days
sergey pedor
was away looking after his ailing mother
but his family was trapped in their home
18 old makita
nine-year-old alisa his wife tatiana
[Music]
like so many others they decided it was
too dangerous to stay
i told my wife i'm sorry i couldn't be
there to protect you but she said don't
worry we'll get through it
everything will be good
as they made a run for it sir he tracked
tatiana's phone when it showed up at an
emergency room at the hospital 20
minutes later this photo came up on his
phone
an image that resonated around the world
the bodies of children of a family
struck down
i recognize my children even though
their faces were hidden he said yeah i
was able to recognize them by their
clothing their backpacks in the suitcase
that must have been a terrible moment
for you
yeah
tatiana the woman he'd known since high
school had died too
maquita was a software engineer like his
father
and your daughter just nine years old
very
yep
smile
very nice
don't uh
are you more angry or more sad it was
like the
i'm trying to keep my emotions to myself
he said i'm angry at russia at putin and
the russians keep silent
sir he will not keep silent journalists
even showing us their blood-stained
suitcases he wants the world to know
what happened here
he says their story is all he has left
your whole family
all family
yes
your wife your children
two dogs
yes you have nothing left
i'm alone
you can see that he's still in a state
of shock i told him we admire his
strength and courage he said i know i
have to go on living but now i have
nothing to live for
vlad
charlie
absolutely horrific yeah we all remember
that picture we all remember that
picture it is
unbelievably horrific
it was all i could do to keep back the
tears um
charlie before you go charlie i'm
curious number one i thank him so much
for sharing the story seeing his little
girl blow out the candle on her birthday
cake is something we can all relate to
seeing the mother playing with her
children on an amusement ride something
we can all relate to does he have any
idea what he can possibly do next where
will he where will he go what will he do
i realize he's still in
he can't go back to his home because
it's ruined uh he wants to make sure
that this message goes out he wanted to
speak with us he is in a state of shock
but he is very determined and that's why
i said are you more angry than sad i
think he's angry he's angry with the
russians and he wants people in the
united states and the world to know uh
what's happened i guess so you know they
wouldn't have died in vain but you know
he's still in a state of shock and just
the fact that he found out from looking
at that photo that's how he found out
that's just that's horrific
yes yeah i looked at that picture too
and i when i saw the picture i thought
these are somebody's children somebody's
family that's what we all need to
remember every time i hear the air sign
thank you charlie hear the air siren or
the warning you know that somebody is
possibly in grave danger and may not
make it big holes in a family and in
this case a family completely wiped out
this man's life is back to square one
yeah and the thing that he was tracking
her on his phone and so the hope was
that he was going to be reunited with
her and then to see those images and
realize it's your children and they were
running to be safe yes
thank you charlie